buon pomeriggio a tutti sono anna
tampieri e oggi
di un legno che si è trasformato in osso
sono un ricercatore del consiglio
nazionale delle ricerche e coordino il
gruppo bioceramici in un istituto che si
occupa di sviluppare materiali ceramici
per applicazioni strategiche
applicazioni nel settore aerospaziale e
biomedicale appunto il mio settore
il mio lavoro come tutti i lavori di
ricerca che intendano sviluppare
innovazione vera capace di presentarsi
al mercato e di reggere le sfide di un
mercato globale necessita di lavorare in
grandi team multidisciplinari dove chi
conosce ciò che è tecnicamente possibile
e quindi chimici fisici ingegneri deve
stare in continuo contatto con chi
invece conosce profondamente il problema
nel mio caso clinici chirurghi medici
biologi e a questo proposito alcuni anni
fa incontrai un mio collega chirurgo col
quale collaboravamo i numerosi progetti
europei aveva una faccia da funerale gli
chiedemmo che cosa fosse successo
si disse che era stato chiamato per
un'emergenza e una ragazza aveva avuto
un incidente in motorino aveva una tibia
completamente distrutta praticamente
esplosa ci chiese cosa poteva fare per
evitare le procedure classiche che
prevedono l'utilizzo di impianti come
per esempio l'impianto di lisa roba che
vedete in questa immagine
questo impianto passa attraverso i
tessuti molli e blocca i due monconi
ossei tenendoli a una distanza minima
così che l'osso sia in grado di
autorigenerarsi e distanzia i due
monconi in modo da riformare
e l'intero gap mancante naturalmente
questa procedura e dolorosissima per il
paziente richiede tantissimi mesi tempi
superiori all'anno
il paziente deve restare allettato non
può lavorare non può andare a scuola
quindi questa tecnologia oltretutto
anche il problema che passando
attraverso la cute e tessuti molli molto
spesso porta all insorgenza di infezioni
ortopedica che sono difficilissime da
debellare
e quindi molto spesso abbiamo una
prognosi negativa cioè si arriva all
amputazione della gamba e l'utilizzo di
protesi artificiali questo caso descrive
un problema molto più frequente di
quello che si pensa la rigenerazione di
grandi segmenti di osso portanti carico
e cioè delle braccia e delle gambe
in effetti ho un problema a cui ancora
la tecnologia non ha dato risposta è un
problema clinico che non ha risposta e
la scienza la nuova scienza della
medicina rigenerativa sta studiando da
circa vent'anni nuove tecnologie e nuovi
materiali per riuscire a produrre
impianti adatti alla rigenerazione di
questi grandi segmenti di osso mancante
questi impianti devono essere il più
possibile simili al tessuto che si va a
sostituire quindi al nostro osso infatti
questi impianti vengono posizionati tra
i due monconi ossei e le cellule entrano
nell'impianto lo colonizzano lo
riconoscono come tale e cominciano a
digerirlo e ricostruirlo cioè danno
origine al cosiddetto processo di
rimodellamento osseo
alla fine dopo un certo tempo l'impianto
scompare e al suo posto ci sarà tessuto
neoformato il nostro il mio gruppo di
ricerca ed io eravamo senz'altro in
grado di
produrre integralmente la chimica del
tessuto osseo che è un calcio fosfato
complesso chiamato idrossiapatite ma non
eravamo in grado di produrre una
struttura così complessa come quella del
tessuto osseo
il nostro tessuto osseo ha una struttura
caratterizzata da sei ordini gerarchici
di organizzazione ognuno ad una
specifica scala dimensionale dalla nano
fino alla macroscala questa struttura
non viene è difficilissimo da riprodurre
e non ci sono tecnologie ad oggi abbiamo
tentato con il 3d manifacturing con lo
stampaggio a iniezione tecniche di
freeze drying ma nessuna di queste
tecniche è in grado di riprodurre una
struttura così complessa che d'altra
parte invece è estremamente importante
per le brillanti proprietà meccaniche
del nostro tessuto osseo che è duro ma
nello stesso tempo a un sufficiente
grado di elasticità è leggero e nello
stesso tempo e tollerante ai danni e
alle fratture
se la nostra cellula non vede un
impianto così organizzato non in grado
di riprodurre rigenerare un tessuto
neoformato meccanicamente competente ma
produce soltanto un osso disordinato che
non ha proprietà meccaniche quindi
inadatto alla rigenerazione di gambe e
braccia
a questo punto non avevamo soluzioni
mentre navigavo nel web per studiare le
strutture naturali
mi sono imbattuta in bellissime immagini
tratte dalle metamorfosi di ovidio dove
ninfe avevano estremità trasformate in
alberi per sfuggire all'ira degli dei
o viceversa alberi avevano estremità
umane e quindi fu folgorata dall'idea
che in effetti la natura poteva fornirci
qualcosa di molto simile al nostro
tessuto osseo il legno il legno in
effetti alle stesse funzioni del nostro
osso funzioni di sostegno e funzioni di
trasporto dei nutrimenti dalla terra
fino alle parti più alte della pianta il
passaggio dalle metamorfosi di ovidio
alla trasformazione biomorfi ca è stato
breve
quindi abbiamo cominciato a studiare
tutti i legni per trovare quello che più
mi ma va il nostro tessuto alla fine
abbiamo trovato un legno della famiglia
del bambù il rattan un legno che è
perfettamente
è sovrapponibile alla struttura
gerarchicamente organizzata del nostro
osso
le immagini mostrano la perfetta
similitudine della struttura a canali
lamellare del nostro osso e abbiamo
iniziato a studiare come trasformare
chimicamente questo legno per mantenere
la sua struttura ma trasformarlo
chimicamente nel idrossiapatite siamo
partiti da un processo di
carbonizzazione in alta temperatura in
assenza di ossigeno e quindi abbiamo
tenuto un rattan carbonizzato
perfettamente identico strutturalmente e
attorno a queste struttura di carbonio
attraverso infiltrazione di gas reattivi
abbiamo cambiato la chimica prima
introducendo il calcio lione
fondamentale per il nostro osso e poi
arrivando quindi alla trasformazione di
un calcio fosfato complesso cioè
l'idrossiapatite naturalmente abbiamo
usato gas allo stato supercritico per
riuscire a facilitare la permeabilità e
la reattività dei gas
a questo punto passò il testimone a
lorenzo pradella l'amministratore
delegato della startup che cura
l'industrializzazione di questo progetto
grazie anna
poter offrire ad una ragazza con una
gamba distrutta da un incidente in moto
la possibilità di evitare una probabile
sequenza di interventi chirurgici con
lunghi tempi di guarigione ma di poter
addirittura tornare a camminare non solo
sulle proprie gambe ma sulle proprie
ossa ricostruite utilizzando qualcosa
già esistente in natura come ha detto
ann
questo sembra e sembrava essere
solamente un sogno
in effetti già albert einstein ci disse
che qualunque cosa noi immaginassimo di
fare molto probabilmente la natura aveva
già provveduto ad inventarla
e in effetti abbiamo esempi che ci
permettono di comprendere come questa
via che è la base come concetto della
biomimesi che anna così brillantemente
illustrato sia effettivamente
percorribile il velcro ad esempio è
stato inventato prendendo ispirazione da
gli uncini del fiore della bardana e fu
brevettato nel 1941 da george del
mistral
analogamente la progettazione del gate
building center di harare nello zimbabwe
ha preso ispirazione dalla mimare la
capacità di auto raffreddamento e
ventilazione dei termitai africani
esplorare e comprendere le strategie
della natura ed imparare ad adattarla e
utilizzarle nel risolvere problemi
quotidiani è il processo è la via che
unitamente allo sviluppo della
biodiversità e dell'ecosostenibilità
permette di creare opportunità anche di
crescita delle comunità locali
ed effettivamente questo è il viaggio
che abbiamo avuto l'opportunità di
intraprendere nello sviluppo di questa
tecnologia innovativa inventata da anna
e quindi nella possibilità partendo da
ratan che
vedete nelle mie mani di ottenere un
nuovo materiale che sia effettivamente
adatto ad essere impiantato
chirurgicamente nei pazienti per poter
ottenere quel risultato che si ambiva e
si sognava di poter raggiungere partendo
dal caso della ragazza con la gamba
distrutta dall'incidente in moto il
rattan ha delle proprietà uniche e tra
queste come è stato sottolineato la
robustezza e la flessibilità ma quanto
queste caratteristiche ricordano le
caratteristiche delle nostre ossa e
quanto anche noi
durante la nostra vita vorremmo molto
spesso essere robusti ma flessibili
nella nostra vita quotidiana
il nostro sostituto osseo 3d quindi non
solo beneficia della migliore chimica
possibile in grado di riprodurre la
composizione della matrice dell'osso ma
anche di ciò che è mamma natura ci ha
donato attraverso il rattan quindi
un'architettura interna e una struttura
unica in grado effettivamente di offrire
la possibilità di un processo
rigenerativo una volta inserito
nell'organismo e durante lo sviluppo
preclinico abbiamo avuto modo di
mostrare comprendere come effettivamente
questo possa avvenire e come questo
materiale venga progressivamente
riassorbito e permetta di non solo
ricostruire la porzione mancante ma
anche e soprattutto di avere un processo
di unificazione mineralizzazione e
remodeling in grado di ottenere un osso
funzionale con caratteristiche naturali
stiamo completando un importante studio
clinico presso l'ospedale
dell'università di leeds in inghilterra
eseguito dal professor peter già nudi
dove innesti superiori a tre centimetri
nel bacino stanno conducendo ad un
risultato che evidenzia quanto appena
descritto abbiamo ottenuto nello
sviluppo preclinico del prodotto
ma siamo partiti dal rennes e quindi
torniamo a rattan questa pianta
rampicante questa palma rampicante che
cresce prevalentemente in paesi del sud
est asiatico e dove rappresenta una
fonte di ricchezza per alcuni di questi
territori
ad esempio per l'isola di sumatra in
indonesia
tutti i paesi produttori di bambù era
temp sono raggruppati in un'associazione
denominata inbar international rattan in
bambù organization e grazie alla
collaborazione con la task force del
rattan stiamo cercando di sviluppare una
collaborazione che auspicabilmente ci
porterà alla realizzazione delle
cosiddette sostenevo il piano plantation
cioè piantagioni sostenibili che avremo
l'ambizione di far diventare la fonte
principale per di questa materia prima
per la realizzazione di questo
innovativo materiale su scala globale
questo ci permetterà di approcciare
questo sviluppo di business attraverso
un un'economia ecosostenibile che possa
offrire anche opportunità di crescita ai
territori dove dove la nostra materia
prima viene effettivamente prodotta e
realizzata innovazione dirompente o per
meglio dire lisart il technology questo
concetto che ci porta a sviluppare
tecnologie innovative ma senza
dimenticare bio diversità
ecosostenibilità e opportunità di
crescita sia culturale che economica per
i territori coinvolti all'interno di un
processo all'interno del processo di un
prodotto o allargando la visione a
livello globale e questo ci porta e ci
riporta all'inizio del nostro viaggio
laddove scienza visione tecnologie e
innovazione si sono un
per attraverso una visione che portasse
a trovare un innovazione ad un bisogno
clinico di quella ragazza che aveva
subito un trauma così violento da
distruggergli una gamba bene vi abbiamo
raccontato una storia che sembra quasi
un miracolo
in realtà è una tecnologia alla
frontiera dell'innovazione
inoltre ci fa capire come la sinergia
uomo natura abbia un potere ed un valore
veramente molto grandi
questo approccio innovativo apre scenari
completamente nuovi nel mondo
scientifico e per di più alle
caratteristiche come ci ha spiegato
lorenzo di essere ecosostenibile e segue
addirittura i dettagli di una
blueeconomy che va oltre concetti della
green economy cioè non solo riduzione
delle emissioni negative ma addirittura
zero emissioni o segni negativi e questo
è quello che il nostro progetto fa
poiché parte dalla natura per tornare
alla natura passando attraverso l'uomo
con emissioni zero